- [Voiceover] We're asked
to express the area of the
entire rectangle below as a trinomial.
We have our rectangle here
and it's broken up into
these three smaller rectangles.
And we see for all of these rectangles,
the height here is four
units and then the widths
are expressed in terms,
or at least the first two,
are expressed in terms of
x and then this last one
has a width of two.
So what's the area of
the entire rectangle?
I encourage you to pause the
video and think about it.
What's the area of this blue, this blue,
it looks like a square,
but let's just call it
a rectangle, which all
squares are rectangles
so that's safe.
Well, it's going to be the
height times the width.
So the area here is
going to be the height,
which is four, times the width,
which is x squared.
And then to that, we want
to add the area of this,
I guess we could say this
salmon colored rectangle
and well that's going
to be the height four
times the width 3x.
So we could say four times 3x,
we could write it like that,
but what is 4 times 3x?
Well, that's going to be 12x.
You have 3x four times, I have 12 xs,
so that's going to be 12x.
12x is the area of this
salmon colored rectangle.
And then, finally, the area
of this green rectangle,
we actually can figure out
it exactly, we don't even
have to express it in terms of a variable.
Its height is four, its width is two,
so the area's going to be
four times two, or eight.
And we are done.